السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
اتمنى ان تكثيرا وبعد ما استمعت تم حائل
حفزاره كلمات الملهمه اشعر بالخجل
متواضعه
قيل لامي
انها ولدت هذا لن يعيش
اكثر من ست سنوات
وعمر العاشره
راح يعيش حتى 18
ثم 24
كان في احسن تقدير راح تعيش حتى الثانيه
والاولاد
عمري اليوم 50
التعييات
ترمانينيه امشي بسرعه
باقي لكم وباذن الله ساعيش حتى عمر
الخامسه والسبعون
اعيشها في سعاده وفي عافيه وفي النجاح
سنين زكريا ابراهيم الكاظم وهذه هي رحله
ولدت بفقر الدم المنجد
وهو مرض وراثي
نتيجه
خلل يحصل في ان كريان تمل الحمراء لدينا
هلاليه الشك
وفي نسجد
تتلاصق مع بعض
ها تسبب اختناقا مروريا في تدفق الد
م ونقل الاكسجين الى الاعضاء
فيشكر عضو من الاعضاء
نقصا في هذا الوقت من الاكسجين فيطلق
انذار على هيئه الالم
يصنفه علماء الالم هذا الالم في بعضه بانه
عشب مرات اكثر من الام الولاده
وهو حدث سعيد
تختبره المراه مره مرتين ثلاث عدد من
المرات في حياتنا
ساعتين الى اربع ساعات
ولكم ان تتخيلوا الطفل في عمر ثمان سنوات
يختبر هذا الالم مضاعف عشر مرات
32 مره في الامر
يمتد ما بين خمسه الى 21 يوم
وليس من اطباء حيله سوى تسخين الالم
رحله حياتي
هي امتداد الانوار البيضاء التي زارتني 11
مره
في حياتي
رحله الحياه
هذه الالوان البيضاء
في صدري الدهشه
والدهشه هي المسؤوله عن صناعه حكمه
والحكمه
ساعدتني في استخلاص المعنى
[موسيقى]
ودفعني الى صيانه النفس العميقه
لما كنت طفل
كنت يجوز بقيه الاطفال يلعبون ويمرحون كنت
اسمع المغامرات في حديث الشغف والمتعه في
اعينهم انا اشوف نفسي محروم
يركضون يلعبون دراجه بالكره في تركيا
البحر
يلبسون ما يشتهون الا انا
وكنت اسال نفسي
ماذا يرافقني طوال حياتي بهذا
السؤال الرجل الاولى كان عمري وقتها 18
عام
وحيد القلق مشوش
لماذا
انا اهون عبيد الله
لتصنع
بي وتخلقني لجسد ضعيف
مرض
دوني بطن
مشهد نازاني انا بعمر الخمسين لا زاحم امس
ما زال عالق هذا المشهد بذاكرته
لكن السؤال من انا
من انمي
هل فعلا انا ذلك المخلوق عشق الناس او
اهون عديد الله
انا
احد يعرف رصيده البركه
شهادتي شيء منصوب الى
قليل لا
لكن بكل يعلم باني انا
قائل تسعه الاف فرد في البحرين
بل القائد 27 مليون فرد العالم
اصنع امال
احلاما اتحدث نيابه عنه
في الوقت الذي كنت
افكر باني انا اهون عبيد الله
كان الله يسمع في داخل القاعه
كان الله يصنعني الابل الجديد
9000 فرد يعيشون هذا
استعجلت
جميع الناس تبيعني مستعجل
كم هو مؤثر
انه استيقظ في كل صباح
وان اجد تليفوني غالب 16 الف رساله
حقيقيه وليس مبالغه
من امهات
لاطفال قيل له لان ابناكم لنا يعيشون
طويلا
فلذلك ان يرون حياه ابتداء لحياته
يامنون
ان
يعيشون بقدر عمره
يكونون سعداء بقدر سعان
ناجحين بقدر
اتجاه
شو
فقط لا اقول انا بخير
ناشئه
يطمئنوني ان انا بخير
دائما اقول هل تعجل نعم جميعنا نتعجل
ولان اكتشفت ان حياتي تعتمد عليها تسعه
الاف فرد وامهاتهم
صار
جدا في تاويل الامور
واتانى في اختيار الذات الفعل
وهذا اعطاني
الوقت لان اصنع السكينه والسلام اكتسب
ولاني صرت متاني
بجلال والوقار في عين الاخرين
ولم اكن باكسب ذلك
خارج ت
لك دوله اقع ضمن تلك الشغل
اليوم
لا يجب ان اضعف
لانني الامل
فلا يجب ان اخطا فانني قدوه
لعلنا اقوى شيء او اصعب شيء
تمشي على حافه السكين
ان يؤمن بك تسعه الاف شخص يعملون انك لا
قدوه
اياك ان تصيبهم بخدمه الام
ولدت لابن كهن التجاره وهو خير من يرعى
الحديث
وقد ورثنا من جدي
ولاني انا ابن هن
د فهو يتوقع ويرجو مني
ان اخذ دوره
في رعايه الاسره واداره شؤون تجارته
فاعتذرتم
وقلت له سيدي
اريد ان اعيش بسيطا درويشا
خادما لا بين
لا ارى حياتي تاجرا
لقد التقيت برساله
ووجدت شغف حياتي
اما لماذا
فلان هنالك اناس
رغم هناء حيالهم او حياتهم
لكنهم يموتون
او يموت المرء حزينا
وهم هناء حياته
لانه لم ينتقل
برساله مثل الحدث
ويموت المرء سعيدا
وان كان شقيا
لانه التقى برسالته حتى وان جاءت مت
اخر لكنني كنت الاسعد حقا منكم جميل
[تصفيق]
كنت الاسعد
والاوفر حظهم حظا منهم جميعا لانني التقيت
برساله بشكل ابكر
وعلمت ان هنالك رساله يجب ان
حديث
اطباء وحديث الحياه والموت رحلات الحياه
والموت 11 مره هذه اللي شفتها
علمت بان طول الحياه ما عندي
لكن عندي ساعه
وانا بين خيارين ان اعيش
طويلا او ان اعيش خالدا
اذا مات الفارق ساله كما كم عاش قال خمسين
ستين سبعين ثمانين
الفقياس
هل هذا هو العين الذي ولد
مثلا عبود انا مئه في احسن تقدير
مين بيتكلم
نعم يقولون كاندي
من بعد
لازم بعدين
ولا احفادي يكونون جدورون
يعني في احسن تقدير يذكرني بجيل الثاني من
عيال وبعدين يتحول
الى اسم في اسميه قوي
عندنا
الاسماء اللي عندي ما اعرف ما اعتقد
كم من شخص عاش كم من شخص انت في التاريخ
تعرفه يمكن عاش عشرين سنه
ثلاثين اربعين لكن لا صار حياتي لا زال
اسمه رغم مئات السنين الاف السنين ما زال
موجود
ان تعيش طويله تعيش بالمحتوى والعبد
ان قررت ان اعيش في محتوى
تبتدي يكون
كل يوم من الايام
والذي انا ما قيل
عمود موت رخيصه
رخيصه شنو
فوق
اموت موته العاجز فوق سرير العجز
انا اريد ان اموت اما فوق سج
اده في الاوقاتنا في رعايه عيالي
فلا جميل جدا
علمتني ان فداء اردت ان اموت يجب ان اموت
خاويه
قد انتهيت من مسكونيات
لن اخلع ثوب المحامي ولن البس ثوب الراحه
واذا ما اراد الله ان ياخذ
ني اليه قد ياخذني قائما في خدمتي
عيال
وبلادي او برساله التي خلقت من اجلها
[تصفيق]
الرحله الاخيره
كانت قبل من خمس سنوات في وحده
العنايه المركزه فيها طبيب
عندما زارتني الالوان البيضاء
علمت باني ميت
فساد نفسي وهذا هو الموت
هذه هي المشكله
ما كنت
ابدا ما كنت خايف
لكنه
فراق الاحب
راح اجي على دمك ايدين خاليتين ما عندي
شيء ابد
طالع صحيفه القاويه ما فيها شيء
ما عندي الظن
احتلت على
الحين
متربي
انا جيتك ما عندي شيء
لكنني اهب لك
جميع ذنوب خلق الله
عسى ان تتقبل
وعسى ان تتوسط لي عند عباده في الحقوق
اللي لهم عندي
اذا
كانوا الاطباء مشمونين في ارجاع الحياه 30
طبيب
وكان وراءهم عامل نظافه
ثقيل
متاثر فيه بس ما عندك ما عنده شيء يعرف من
مساعده
يدعو الله ان ينجيك المنجين بقيه ما يعرف
واختار
ان يخصص تلك اللحظه والدعوات لي على امان
في غربه
خلال نصف ساعه
تغيرت اسارير وبشائر وجه الاطباء وهذا
يهندان
نظرني فقالوا
على السلامه ستعيش
صلي لله شاكر
فعلا
فرجت قلت لكم
وكان
سؤال
تشكي لهذه
عشان اعرف قيمه التسام
هل احتجت
الى هذه الرحله
قيمه الانسان
في ان انت توظف انسان تفكرني انت مليت
عليها الوظيفه يمكن الله رجعني من الاطباء
يمكن دعوه للفقير
الصوره الاخيره
هي سوره تجمعني بسني مغفور
صاحب السجنون امين الملكي
امين خليفه بن سلمان خليفه رئيس مجلس
الوزراء رحمه الله
حينما شكر جميع الاطباء الذين
ساعدوا ساعدوه في ارجاع حياتي
وقد بحثت طويلا عن العامل ليكون معنا
كثير من القصص وكثير من النواتج اللي انا
فتحت الان في صدوركم
انا مو وظيفه يعطيكم
وظيفتي ان اوقظ السؤال في
كل شخص
سوف يرجع الى منزله عند سؤال
انا ما عندي
شكرا للحوار البيضاء التي قريبه
[تصفيق]